An intriguing character from Marvel comics
catalogue will be getting his very first solo
movie vehicle in 2021: Shang-Chi, Master of
Kung Fu.
Who is Shang-Chi, and how did he come to be
the master of kung-fu, and what is his place
within the world of Marvel Comics?
We're here to break down the details for you.
You may be aware that in the early 1970s,
everybody was kung fu fighting.
Or at least they wanted to be.
This was largely thanks to Bruce Lee, who
had been exposed to American audiences via
the television series The Green Hornet and
with starring roles in films including Game
of Death and the posthumously-released Enter
the Dragon, which kicked open the door for
future superstars like Jackie Chan.
The TV series Kung Fu, which starred actor
David Carradine, is said to have originally
been developed for Bruce Lee.
Marvel hoped to adapt the series to cash in
on the martial arts craze.
But the House of Ideas was unable to obtain
the rights...
"As quickly as you can, snatch the pebble
from my hand."
so then-Marvel Publisher Stan Lee turned to
creators Steve Englehart and Jim Starlin to
come up with an original kung fu-based property.
The character they created would go on to
become a Marvel mainstay.
In the late '80s, long before Marvel came
to dominate the box office, Stan Lee attempted
to get a Shang-Chi movie off the ground starring
Brandon Lee, Bruce's son.
It never materialized.
Not everyone was convinced that Master of
Kung Fu would be an instant hit, so Marvel
introduced the character in a dead-end book
with the clunky title of Special Marvel Edition,
which had up to that point published 14 issues
of reprints of older Marvel stories.
Much like Spider-Man, who first appeared in
Amazing Fantasy #15, Shang-Chi debuted in
the pages of Special Marvel Edition #15, published
in December 1973.
The public quickly took notice.
It took only two issues for the book's former
title to be dropped.
It was renamed Hands of Shang-Chi: Master
of Kung Fu for the remainder of its run, which
lasted until 1983.
Shang-Chi enjoyed a respectable level of popularity
throughout the '70s, making guest appearances
in several of Marvel's flagship books and
interacting with some of its most high-profile
characters.
Despite this success, it was, as they say,
a different time, and some elements of the
character's backstory were more than a little
questionable.
Chief among these problems was Shang-Chi's
lineage.
In his very first appearance, he was presented
as the son of the evil Fu Manchu, an overtly
racist supervillain who had appeared in pulp
novels and movies throughout the 20th Century.
The character was among the most popular of
the so-called "Yellow Peril" villains, which
spawned a number of devious, heartless Asian
evildoers such as Flash Gordon archvillain
Ming the Merciless and the Batman villain
Ra's Al Ghul.
Marvel obtained the rights from Fu Manchu's
creator, British novelist Sax Rohmer, and
while their characterization was a touch more
dignified, many Asian readers nevertheless
found the character to represent a demonization
of their culture.
In his original origin, Shang-Chi was raised
by his father to be the ultimate assassin,
but quickly came to reject Fu Manchu's evil
ways.
Over the years, the two would clash repeatedly.
In later years, the identity of the hero's
father would be retconned to actually be the
immortal sorcerer Zheng Zhu, who for decades
had simply been using "Fu Manchu" as an alias.
But this was largely due to the rights reverting
back to Rohmer's estate rather than a desire
to rehab the character.
Like many of Marvel's heroes, Shang-Chi technically
doesn't have any superpowers.
He was molded by his father into the ultimate
weapon, a master practitioner of all forms
of Chinese martial arts.
Not only does this mean that he's an absurdly
skilled fighter, it also means that he has
a level of control over his body that few
characters in the Marvel Universe can match.
He's able to regulate a number of supposedly
involuntary bodily functions.
For example, he can reduce the function of
his nerves to the extent that he's practically
impervious to pain, and can even slow down
the rate at which he bleeds.
He also has a master's knowledge of pressure
points, enabling him to take down opponents
with a single strike, and is known to unleash
a bone-rattling flying kick which packs an
unbelievable amount of force behind it.
Like Captain America, he's said to represent
the peak of human strength, power and agility.
He does, however, boast one skill specific
to only the most skilled of martial artists,
one that raises his abilities to a level slightly
beyond those of fellow non-powered heroes.
Shang-Chi has the ability to focus his chi,
the spiritual energy or "life force" inherent
to all living things.
In real-world martial arts, this practice
is used mainly in meditation and as a way
of controlling one's fear and anger.
In the Marvel universe, the ability can be
honed into a weapon, and Shang-Chi uses it
to augment his skills to devastating effect.
He can temporarily boost his strength and
endurance beyond even peak human levels, dodge
or deflect bullets, and control his body's
reaction to poison or drugs.
Because of these abilities and his utter mastery
of an array of deadly fighting styles, Shang-Chi
is often considered to be the greatest unarmed
combatant in the entire Marvel universe; he
was deemed by no less an authority than Black
Panther to be an even more formidable fighter
than the superpowered Iron Fist.
His mastery over his chi has even received
a technological boost.
At times, he uses a special pair of nunchucks
designed by Tony Stark, which can accumulate
and disperse Shang-Chi's spiritual energy,
unleashing deadly concussive blasts.
Shang-Chi's interactions with other Marvel
heroes have been frequent, but one of his
wilder team-ups was with an unlikely band
of New York-based heroes.
It started with an investigation into the
bizarre slaughter of an entire faction of
Brooklyn mafia members.
Daredevil discovered it was the work of Ulik,
a rock troll hailing from Asgard's underworld
who had come to Earth in search of a mystical
horn.
Daredevil enlisted the aid of Shang-Chi, Black
Widow, a Cloak-less Dagger, and the Punisher
to form the "Marvel Knights" and deal with
Ulik and his minions.
Afterwards, the rest of the group became determined
to bring the Punisher — whose methods they
found to be unsavory — to justice.
They were joined in this dangerous endeavor
by Moon Knight, but the revamped group's efforts
were interrupted by Cloak, who was in the
psychological clutches of the demon Nightmare
and was on a misguided rampage to consume
all evildoers.
After consuming the Punisher, Daredevil, Black
Widow, and Moon Knight, Cloak was halted by
Doctor Strange, whom Dagger had brought in
to assist before things got truly out of hand.
By the end of the series, the Punisher was
still punishing away.
Shang-Chi has occasionally been called upon
to train other heroes in hand-to-hand combat,
including your friendly neighborhood wall-crawler.
During the "Revenge of the Spider-Slayer"
story arc, Spider-Man realized that the villain
Alistair Smythe had found a way to imbue his
Spider-Slayer robots with a version of his
spider-sense.
He created a device to disrupt the ability,
but was forced to set it off manually, deactivating
his own spider-sense in the process.
This caused some difficulty in the subsequent
"Spider Island" event, during which thousands
of heroes, villains, and ordinary citizens
alike developed spider-powers.
On the recommendation of Madame Web, Spidey
went to Shang-Chi for training.
He created a completely new martial arts style
intended to complement Spider-Man's powers,
which he called "The Way of the Spider."
Spider-Man became an even more dangerous fighter
than he already was, using his newfound martial
arts prowess to take down opponents as powerful
and skilled as Spider-Woman and even Shang-Chi
himself.
Shang-Chi has at times been imparted with
superhuman abilities.
During the aforementioned "Spider Island"
event, he was one of the many temporarily
granted the same powers as Spider-Man, a scary
notion if ever there was one.
He used these powers to help dispatch the
threat of the spider-powered supervillains
running roughshod over New York City.
In another incident, Shang-Chi was dispatched
with other Avengers to the fictional island
of Madripoor to deal with an ancient dragon
which had been awakened from its slumber underneath
the island.
Using Pym Particles, Shang-Chi enlarged himself
to match the dragon's Godzilla-like stature,
and promptly defeated it in combat.
In a more recent incident, Shang-Chi volunteered
to investigate the city of Kobe, Japan after
it was struck with the evolution-speeding
Origin Bomb by the godlike entity known as
Ex Nihilo.
While others had been absorbed by the "genesis
matter" which was a by-product of the bombing,
Shang-Chi was able to commune with it, and
in the process gained the ability to produce
an unknown number of duplicates of himself,
each one with the original's memories and
abilities.
It's unknown whether he still possesses this
power.
Back in 2006, when Marvel first announced
its intention to start Marvel Studios and
produce a slate of films featuring some of
its lesser-known characters, virtually no
one was thinking that the endeavor would result
in the single highest-grossing film franchise
of all time.
"Avengers!
Assemble."
The rights to Marvel's most famous properties,
namely Spider-Man and the X-Men, were held
by Sony and Fox respectively, both of which
had created successful film franchises.
Marvel seemed to be coming late to the party,
with a stable of characters that included,
in the order they were announced: Captain
America, The Avengers, Nick Fury, Black Panther,
Ant-Man, Cloak & Dagger, Doctor Strange, Hawkeye,
Power Pack, and Shang-Chi.
Marvel Studios would, of course, go on to
elevate many of these properties to household
name status, although some took considerably
longer to develop than others.
Ant-Man took a full nine years to reach the
big screen, and the pre-teen Power Pack have
yet to get its time in the spotlight.
But finally, well over a decade after the
fact, Shang-Chi stands poised to join the
MCU, thanks in part to another solo vehicle
which became one of Marvel's biggest success
stories and one of the biggest films of 2018.
Black Panther astonished audiences.
Crafted mainly by African-American filmmakers
and featuring a hero who is the king of the
technologically advanced African nation of
Wakanda...
“This never gets old."
the film proved that big-budget blockbusters
created from a specific cultural viewpoint
can resonate strongly with general audiences,
and it even outgrossed the juggernaut that
was Avengers: Infinity War at the domestic
box office.
Taking a cue from this success, Marvel appears
to have gone all-in on diversity, and it's
likely the studio's hope that Shang-Chi and
the Legend of the Ten Rings can strike a similar
chord in pop culture at large.
To this end, the production has been loaded
up with talented people of Asian descent on
both sides of the camera.
Japanese/Irish American Destin Daniel Cretton
will direct from a screenplay by Chinese-American
scribe Dave Callaham, who is contributing
to Warner Brothers' upcoming Wonder Woman
1984 as well as Sony Pictures Animation's
as-yet untitled sequel to Spider-Man: Into
the Spider-Verse.
Chinese-Canadian actor Simu Liu has landed
the title role, and the suddenly ubiquitous
rapper-turned-actor Awkwafina will appear
among the supporting cast.
Legendary Chinese actor Tony Leung will co-star
as the Mandarin, an iconic villain who many
fans feel was previously given extremely short
shrift.
The title of Shang-Chi's solo vehicle quickly
got the attention of Marvel fans, alluding
as it does to a mysterious terrorist organization
that has lurked in the shadows of the MCU
since its inception.
The Ten Rings are the group responsible for
Tony Stark's kidnapping in Iron Man, they've
been alluded to in both of that film's sequels
as well as Ant-Man.
They're led by none other than the real Mandarin,
who famously a ring on every finger in the
comics.
This is not the phony Trevor Slattery or his
handler Aldrich Killian, both of whom falsely
laid claim to the Mandarin name.
"Where's the Mandarin?
Where is he?"
"Whoa!
Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa!
He's here.
He's here, but he's not here.
He's here but he's not here."
In Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings,
this group will finally step out of the shadows
and truly make their presence felt.
The Ten Rings are dedicated to nothing less
than the destabilization of the entire planet,
sowing the kind of chaos which will lead to
the collapse of world governments and create
a power vacuum.
They've butted heads with Iron Man, Black
Widow, and Nick Fury, but they'll soon face
the Master of Kung-Fu, who never met a challenge
that he couldn't kick the absolute crap out
of.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.